you know sometimes uh I think that
parents get a bad rap these days sure
being a parent myself there may be some
personal biases that have helped to lead
me to that conclusion but I think that
there's there's some truth to the idea
it's it's extremely challenging to raise
children in our culture in fact I would
say and I have said before it it has
never been more challenging to raise
kids than it is right now I mean I mean
that in a literal sense that parenting
is harder today than it than it ever was
in the whole history of the human
species and I don't think that that
statement is hyperb
now granted life is easier today in a
number of very important ways if I was
parenting six kids in the 1700s for
instance the chance that all of them
would make it to adulthood would be
pretty slim so for that extremely
significant reason alone I am happy to
be living today rather than back then
but when it comes to the actual Act of
parenting of trying to raise your
children to be competent well-adjusted
decent functional virtuous human beings
in the world we parents in the Modern
Age have to navigate around certain
enormous obstacles that did not exist
until very recently the biggest
challenge is that while we're raising
our children civilization is decaying
all around us we live in a decadent
depraved morally insane culture one that
actively wants to steal our kids' minds
and souls and turn them into hollowed
out husks of human beings now of course
people have lived and parented in
degenerate societies before uh this
unfortunately is a common experience in
the history of human civilization the
difference now is that it's nearly
impossible to escape the degenerate it's
all around us and homes today are filled
with devices that become access points
places where our debased culture can
reach in and grab a child and make him
its prisoner a child can be lost to the
culture before he graduates Elementary
School and and he doesn't even need to
leave his house and when I say lost to
the culture I mean lost in ways
previously unheard of his entire sense
of his own identity his grasp on reality
itself may be destroyed so that's the
unique challenge it's the thing that no
other generation of parent has really
had to deal with certainly not in the
same way or to the same extent so there
is no Road mapap for us there's no how
to guide the parenting wisdom passed
down through the generations before us
kind of runs off the tracks before it
reaches us and we're left out on our own
to figure it
out this is why parents today deserve
some Grace I believe we're out here in
the thick of it we're in the trenches
doing our best
cut us some
slack well some of us at least some of
us are doing our best to raise our
children to be decent people in spite of
all this and some of us on the other
hand are doing our best to make our
children into the worst human beings the
world has ever
seen and in some cases we must admit the
the hardest parenting environment has
been met by the most insufferably awful
parents of all time and that's where our
criticism should be pointed pointed for
example at this woman her name is AR and
she is a she has a Tik Tok account where
she posts about and promotes her unique
parenting style a style that as it turns
out is is not nearly as unique as it
should be in fact there there are a lot
of parents that parent basically like
this so here's one video that's gone
viral this week it now has nearly 2
million views and more depressingly it
has almost 70,000 likes uh the video
shows various pictures and videos of her
toddler son along with captions
explaining her parenting strategy and I
will read the captions as we watch it
here's the
video says controversial ways we're
raising our
son he has his own iPad screen time is
not limited he eats what he likes he's
never forced to eat something he doesn't
like and if there's nothing he likes we
go buy him something that he will
eat he's allowed to try and have candy
juice soda
Etc we co- sleep and contact nap
whatever that is if he wants something
from the store he will get it he doesn't
have a strict bedtime
routine he will not be made to do
something he does not want to
[Music]
do his feelings and boundaries are just
as valid as ours when he says no it
means
no there we go poor kid all right so uh
no means
no well that's a problem uh for me
because my kids say no to doing their
chores to going to bed to brush ing
their teeth to getting dressed in the
morning
Etc well let me clarify my kids my kids
absolutely would never say no to me when
I tell them to do any of those things um
they know that saying no to Dad isn't
going to fly but if they thought they
could get away with it they would
absolutely say no to all those things if
no was an option on the menu they would
choose it for nearly every productive
and healthy thing I tell them to do
that's because kids have an extremely
limited ability to understand that there
are benefits to doing something you
don't want to do the concept of delayed
gratification is very difficult for a
child to grasp and at a certain age they
they they literally just don't get it at
all they don't understand the
concept uh it's impossible at a certain
age now that child there in the in the
in the video my my daughter is not much
older than him and and I have on many
occasions just for fun you know asked
her to explain why she doesn't want to
do something that she says she doesn't
want to do like I'll add ask her to do
something I'll tell her to do something
and she'll say she doesn't want to do it
and I'll say and I'll say why you why
don't you want to do it and the answer
is almost always because I don't want to
which isn't her being disrespectful or
defiant she she literally doesn't know
why she doesn't want to do the thing or
why she does want to do something she
doesn't understand her own feelings
certainly not well enough to articulate
them um she may have a good reason for
not wanting to do something or she may
have a bad reason or she may have no
reason she can't figure that out that's
why she has two loving intelligent
parents to figure it out for her now
most of the parenting choices if you can
call them that that you see in that
video uh if you can call them parenting
choices anyway that you see in the video
are are are so over-the-top ridiculous
that you would hope they'd require no
further comment obviously giving
unlimited screen time to a toddler is
deranged you are guaranteeing that he
will be hooked on screens and spend his
entire childhood sitting around staring
at a little box that's what you're
guaranteeing it's not that it might turn
out that way it is 100% guaranteed to
turn out that way and letting a child
eat whatever he wants especially
combined with the unlimited screen time
means that he will be morbidly obese
well before he makes it to high school
guaranteed giving him whatever he wants
from the store means that he will be
spoiled into materialistic again it
doesn't mean that he might turn out that
way but that he absolutely with total
certainty will turn out that way all of
this you would hope is
obvious but if you look at the way many
parents handle their kids these days it
would seem that these points are not so
obvious and and whether parents are
making all these mistakes or not or
making them to this extreme degree or
not it's certainly the case that many
struggle to understand one basic fact
about raising children and the fact is
this kids need structure boundaries
routine and guidance they need all those
things and when I say they need those
things I mean they need them they need
them in the same way they need food and
clothing and a roof over their head
um that doesn't mean that we should
never give our children the ability to
choose something to you know to actually
have a choice the ability to pick a path
and walk down it it means that their
choices especially when they're very
young should be extremely limited and
controlled and as they get older you
progressively expand their choices and
and you drop some of the limitations
until they're adults at which point if
you've done your job they can go out
into the world of Limitless options and
relative freedom and they can make
hopefully the right choices because
they've been given the moral formation
they need to make the right choices as
you might know we're all fans of our
friends at genus cell here but I'll just
take my word for it though Ella from
Rockford says I have both age and acne
spots and this stuff is actually fading
both of them this Serum is worth every
penny Ella is raving about the famous
Dark Spot Corrector from genus cell a
must have after months of record heat
and humidity sunspots brown spots disc
coloration and even red inflame patches
all disappear in front of your very eyes
and here's the genus cell amazing
guarantee you'll see results on day one
or money back so take advantage of genus
cell's most popular package which now
includes the Dark Spot Corrector plus
the classic genus cell bags and
puffiness treatment and immediate
effects all at about 70% off so you can
try the best skin care in the world for
yourself completely risk-free it's
simple got to genucell.com Walsh and
start looking years even decades younger
say goodbye to dark and liver spots bags
of puffiness under the eyes and crows
feet at genucell.com Walsh that's
genucell.com
Walsh now if you don't give your child
struct structure boundaries routine and
guidance then not only do they grow up
to be terrible people due to a lack of
moral intellectual formation but they
also grow up to be plagued with anxiety
and uncertainty you know we're told that
childhood anxiety is on the rise it's
reached epidemic levels we're told that
kids are so
anxious well that's not because there's
some kind of mysterious mental illness
going around it's simply because many
kids are growing up in environments
without structure without boundaries
without routine and without guidance
this makes them uncertain confused
flustered
overwhelmed which is another way of
saying
anxious the reason that kids ask a
million questions every day is because
they don't understand very much about
the world and this lack of understanding
makes them uneasy and they look to their
parents to shine some light so that they
can feel more confident and comfortable
in the world but what if all they hear
from their parents is I don't know it's
up to you you make your own decisions do
whatever you want be whoever you want to
be the world is your oyster
well this is not an empowering message
for kids it's not liberating it's
actually suffocating because it drowns
them in unease and uncertainty it leaves
them lost and
alone now does that mean that we should
take away our children's
freedoms um yes in a certain sense if by
Freedom you mean the ability to do
whatever you want but in another deeper
sense uh no this is actually giving your
child freedom in fact a childhood full
of structure and rules and guidance is
is really the most freeing sort of
childhood you know I've used this
analogy before that if you've got a guy
who's lost in the
wilderness um and you want to free that
guy do you free him by taking away his
compass and map so that no one's telling
him what to do or do you free him by
giving him a compass and a map so the
man may be out in a wide open space he
may be able to go wherever he wants the
essence of Freedom if by Freedom we just
mean doing whatever you want but he's
trapped because he doesn't know which
way he should go or where any of the
paths
lead and a person who comes along and
eliminates most of those potential paths
and tells him which direction to walk is
is is limiting his environment and
taking away options but also at the same
time freeing him true human freedom is
not simply being able to do anything you
want but it's understanding what you
should do
you cannot really choose anyway unless
you know what what you're choosing and
you know what the consequences are and
that's what parents are
for but some parents too many including
the one on Tik Tok here don't understand
that basic fact and those parents are
today canceled if You' like to see what
else I have to say you can access my
full show by going to dailywire.com or
by going to the Matt wall Show Twitter
page hope to see you there Godspeed